okay let's start with that are women to
blame for hookup culture what do the
gals think I think it is fully or not
fully do you want May elaborate go ahead
fire away all right so I think I think
men have been the same for as long as we
can remember I think the fact that women
have become more loose with hooking up
on the first date hooking up on the
second date I think that's women decide
when sex happens and I think sex got
easy so love got hard and I think that's
women driven completely nowadays
MH sex easy love got hard okay yeah I
can jump in and piggy back on that
actually um I do agree I think that
women hold that key I think that you
know as as I've gotten older you know my
20s I might have had a different answer
for that and now in my 30s I'm realizing
like yeah you know we have to value and
love ourselves a little bit more and
hold ourselves to that higher standard
so I do agree with that what about Joel
what do you
think um no I do agree um and I've never
even through of my 20s never been the
type to do that like sleep around or
anything but um I have friends that are
like that but I also feel like nowadays
it's like if you don't you're just men
are so used to that
that you kind of almost feel like
pressured to to to be that type of girl
even like on Instagram on everything
you're like if you're if you don't fall
into that category you're just gonna
like miss your opportunity because men
are just so used to what what the next
best thing is okay you feel like men
will treat you how you them to treat you
oh yes no for sure for sure but I just
feel like now that men are so
conditioned to this way that it's it's
hard it's harder it's harder to go out
there being like a good
girl like a good girl like just more um
I don't know the right word I'm looking
for I just like it's harder for for good
women to to get out there more
traditional you more traditional exactly
I think what Jillian you're saying too
is men like reward promiscuity B Bas on
you know their school all day every day
looking yeah and I do think because of
us but it's just been this way for a
while now that that's what they're used
to so then you go out try to be
traditional you don't even get like
attention at
all um Tiffany tell me that you just
that you disagree it's men's I
mean I feel like it's 50 like hookup
culture is normalized these days um
women are definitely
uh giving in more than they used to and
um it's just like a normal thing it
seems
like so at what point did yall come to
the re to the realization that it's
women that control access to
intimacy I what age say at at what age
did you have this Revelation we'll start
with you
Beth I think kind of like Christy said I
think as you get get older you realize
kind of the Dynamics of dating um I
would say early 30s I'm in my late 30s
now unfortunately but yeah I would say
early 30s you kind of
realize that you kind of not I don't
want to say we decide when that happens
but I don't know I think it leans
majority wise on females when that does
happen in a relationship when you're
dating or however casual or serious it
is I think my early 30s I realized oh
this kind of I determine how comfortable
I am with everything so I would say
early 30s yeah
and the rest of the gals uh we got 24 33
I think uh Beth you're the older one in
the group what about the rest of
you I'm actually not too far from Beth
I'm 36 so um I would say also in my
early 30s and I will say that too it's
it's difficult sometimes when you feel a
mutual attraction so so there is that
aspect of it too that you know we don't
want to like you know gloss over that
piece of it because there is sometimes a
very mutual connection and you feel like
that might be the next you know logical
step or you might be a good time to do
that but then when you sit back in your
20s and you realize like okay I made
some mistakes here and I can learn from
these and then these relationships were
not fruitful or it did not end up in
marriage which would be the ultimate
goal in my opinion anyway um then that's
what I would consider you know like a
failed a mistake on my part so yeah we
have this conversation a lot me and mof
when it comes to this realization
because
there's there's a contingent of women
that will hear the conversations that we
talk about they're like I hate you guys
you're misogynist who hurt you you must
have a little PP you know stuff like
that and then there's the other part
where it's like huh what they're saying
actually starts to make sense if you
really listen to it you start connecting
the dots it's like oh okay
so there's this notion that if a lock
can be open by any key it's a shitty
lock and there's a notion that I've
master key can open up any lock it's a
good key with you know you got the
masculine and The Feminine and the key
in the lock there um so the the gals
hold sorry women are the ones that
determine when intimacy happens at the
end of the day like you're The
Gatekeepers of sex right men are The
Gatekeepers of the relationships men
decide when it's going to turn from
informal to a formal commitment right um
that's generally the way that it goes
there's some lines that kind of get
blurred with that where like you know
we've seen women sometimes on the show
and they'll and they'll just sort of be
like well you know I really like this
guy a lot and I'm waiting for him to ask
me to be you know the girlfriend sort of
thing and I tell them all the same thing
it's like why don't you lean in and say
hey where do we stand right it's like
well I don't know it's so there's a lot
of confusion around that um it's
interesting that we start the show with
only Tiffany kind of on the 50-50 side
so 50/50 so um what is it of men for
hookup
culture uh I mean um whenever I I feel
like let's
see if I were to go out to a bar I feel
like all the men there are just kind of
after like one thing they want to find
the pretty girl they want to bring her
home um they don't want
anything serious because they want to do
it all again next week MH um so
I don't know I feel like if girls are
there too it's kind of like the same
I'm it's just kind of like a I'm on a
teeter
totter I mean girls don't have to
indulge though right that's true girls
don't have
to with the help of like alcohol it
makes it easier for the guys definitely
but then again at the end of the day
it's always the girls decision yeah and
there's a lot of
monkey there's a lot of other people
doing it's like oh I should go along
with it cuz I'm going to feel like an
outcast if I don't participate right um
yeah there's always the argument from
usually like the tradcon side of the
equation you know the traditional
conservatives where they're like well
men need to Bear you know some of the
responsibility here and it's like that's
fine if all women were pure and they
were going out doing you know nasty
things which they're not I think on a
balance probabilities most people would
agree that most women especially younger
women in their 20s um are relatively
permiss ous and free and open and sex
and this all happened since um the
Advent of hormonal birth control by the
way too right because now you could have
free open sex not get pregnant so this
is not recent it's not only happened
last you know in your eras it's happened
in our parents eras too you know kind of
started from there I don't know when it
was it was like the late 60s or
something like that you know they came
out with the hormonal birth control pill
and now there's all these other format
so it's like you can have as much sex as
you want and not deal with the pregnancy
that comes with it I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out